look it's dangle chill
close enough where are you guys going
well dangles not feeling well so I'm
taking them to the doctor what's wrong
dangle actually it's my penis what's
that I have what's known as a venereal
disease how did you get it from I got so
much puppet ass it could be from anyway
I'm not sure Robert that's why we're
going to the doctor there's a lot of
different kinds of penis sicknesses out
there isn't that right q-tip that's
right Dave all kinds sex isn't wrong but
you gotta be right if you're hitting the
sheets thinner wrap it up tight listen
up kids cuz I ain't joking one bad
decision you will be smoking to catch a
VD or don't take it from me I'm gone
Rhea and that's a fact if you can't say
that then call me class
and I wait in genitals just like a trap
and burn up lovers like bacon bats
oh hello Dave Chappelle haven't seen you
for a while
dirty mama
[Music]
[Applause]
this nigga Sabri stay with you to the
end you won't see me every day
but every few years I'll come say hey
that's right no gear for me inside
I'll go
the Herbie
see you Nell mother Wow life is hard
yeah it's not Lisa all right look if you
just remember to keep your genitals out
of harm's way
don't chase money and refrain from
littering you'll be a winner
[Applause]
cute Tim take us home
[Music]